good morning everybody
oh you are awake
um I heard rumors
that some people went to karaoke last
night was that you
I got I got photos this morning from a
friend
um who was also a karaoke the night
before I'm so grateful that you were
here for the second talk some people
even turned up as a first talk today
which was amazing
um I would also like to point out that
while it sounds like I have a deeply
sexy husky voice made for radio
it's not because I was a karaoke last
night
it's actually because I've got a bit of
a head cold I'm recovering from I wish
I'd been in karaoke last night but
unfortunately that's not the reason for
my voice so if my voice breaks at any
point I will endeavor to like repeat
myself but please bear with my my
Frailty at the moment
anyway thanks for coming along to my
talk this morning we want to talk about
clean code has anybody I'm going to try
and see hens has anybody heard of clean
code before
okay about 70 of you that's pretty good
has anybody heard of it but isn't
implementing it at the moment
about half of you okay so we've got a
good mix of people here some of you
using it already I'm glad you are
hopefully you'll be able to use it in
all of your projects
um some of you aren't
I basically want to take you through
today uh the basic principles of clean
code and what the benefits are
um we'll go into some statistics because
we all like numbers we're all software
Engineers we like a bit of stats to back
up our claims uh we'll go into some
justifications if you need them we'll
look at the the whole process of if you
haven't done it before what is it how
can what are the benefits how can you
start implementing it how can you stop
persuading somebody that you should
implement it
um and obviously the main reason we all
want to be here is because we want to
find out how to be that hero
who's already a hero
only three of you okay we'll change that
today
um who am I and why am I here talking to
you about this today my name is Ben
Hello nice to meet you I've been a
software engineer since I used to count
the number of years do I have the number
of years in there no I've actually
changed it to the years because it was
a little depressing for this number to
get higher and higher it made me feel my
age
but I've been software engineer since
1999 I actually started in
um vbasp
oh
thank you I was waiting for the the
commiserations luckily I only did it for
about six months before I then moved on
to PHP
cool thing I know
um and as you can see here I'm a
security and privacy Advocate I'm a
developer Advocate um used to be a
developer advocate for
um or xero I'm now a developer advocate
for sonar uh I I like to work with tools
that help developers be more secure more
effective more productive those kind of
things but prior to becoming a developer
Advocate and the reason why I got into
it is their passion for privacy and
security I used to be a developer I used
to be a Solutions architect and a
business analyst I was a security
consultant for a while I've touched a
lot of areas of of business as I've gone
through my career
I'm definitely one of those jack of all
trades master of none like I haven't
dived very deep if you ask me about
security I'll talk to you all day long
if you want me to rootkit some server
I've got no idea where to start I don't
have that level of depth but I've I've
touched a lot of different systems a lot
of different teams a lot of different
projects
um and some of the things that I've
noticed over time is that the way we
design our software the way we code our
software
um
we often get to the point where
working on that code again at some point
in the future or starting a new project
is
an overhead that we don't necessarily
enjoy nowadays we've got bootstrapping
mechanisms we've got Frameworks
um so it becomes easier but it's still
not necessarily as easy all the time
so I've taken reflections of those and
tried to work out
um where I think clean code comes from
is going to what we can do with it
somebody did ask me yesterday are you
going to be
um fanboying some guy who wrote a book
about it
oh hello there
no I will not
uh if you came here for a fanboy talk I
will not be at all offended if you
decide to um go grab a snack or
something because I want to talk about
my experiences of it and and how it can
potentially help you
anyway enough about me let's look at the
problem what is the problem that clean
code actually solves
how many of you have had to open a
project that the code you haven't
touched for at least a year
about half of you I think the other half
of you are either fairly new to software
engineering which case welcome or you're
lying because we've all had to open this
code at some point where we've gone what
the hell did I do here I've got no idea
what this line of code does you go and
you do a git blame to find out whose
fault it was
it was mine
so we've all been in that position the
other situation we might have as well is
that maybe there's a project that's
quite old and a bug has been raised one
of your teammates was working on it and
now you have to work on it and it is
somebody else's code and ideally they've
written it in a way that you can
actually understand what's going on and
you've got commenting and documentation
all those kind of things or maybe you
work in a digital agency and you work on
five projects at a time and you're
context switching and moving between
them and maybe they're in different
languages maybe the same language but
they're all different sets of business
logic and you're trying to remember
exactly what you did where and why that
order over there is is a different kind
of order to that order over there
because context matters
so I went to have a look for some
statistics because we all love stats
right so the developer coefficient is a
report that was issued by stripe and in
it they uh basically have a look at
those numbers there
um 51 of our time as developers of our
work week not just our developers of our
entire work week is spent working on Bad
Code debugging refactoring and Technical
debt
that's probably a worst case scenario if
you're working on the same project for a
couple of days that will improve
but picking up something from scratch or
starting something from the that either
you've worked on before or somebody else
has been working on you're gonna be
spending more than half of your week
just getting up to speed and trying to
work out where the hell you have to
start
[Applause]
another uh analysis of how software
developers spend their average week
um if you have really good eyesight you
will see that
um one of them in there
I don't have really good oh the first
one in fact is handling interruptions
I don't think they mean like software
interruptions I think they mean meetings
going to the toilet going out for a
coffee
lunch breaks whatever
but on average we spend 16 of our time
coding and 45 of our time reading code
that means we're reading code three
times more than we're writing it
it's not necessarily a bad thing it's
just what we do right
um 22 of our time is spent on
interruptions which again is meetings
and that kind of stacks up with my
experience of probably about a day a
week if I compressed my calendar would
be meetings and then the rest of my time
is working on other stuff so that
probably kind of adds up
but if we think about these two numbers
so if we look at the time coding and the
time reading code and we add those two
together
that's 61 percent
and we had 51 of the time looking at bad
code and refactoring code and
maintaining code which leaves 10 percent
of the time of our week that we're
writing new code new functions
or
um remediating in some way that's not
actually a maintenance item but like
change changing functionality
we're creating
utility for the business that we're
working for
10 of our time that's four hours a week
that we spend writing meaningful code
again worst case scenario but I don't
think that's what Tim Ferriss meant
I think he wants us to have the rest of
the time off not working on the stuff we
don't want to work on
so like I say not every week's going to
be like this sometimes you're working on
a proof of concept and that's going to
be a very different
um
scenario to work on code that might be
bad or needs refactoring sometimes
you're starting a project from scratch
and sometimes you've been working on
something for a couple of days and it's
in your brain again that context is
Switched and it's easier to get back
into the code the next morning when you
arrive at work
my brain just automatically said the
words when you arrive at work
when I arrive at work that's when I go
downstairs with my coffee
has anybody had to go back to the office
yet
some of you I'm sorry
unless you enjoy going to the office I
mean some people do and that's great
um I very much like being able to roll
out of bed in the morning and go
straight into into my office
um anyway so we've got this problem
we've got this scenario of the stats
aren't together they're not uh they are
against us we're only spending four
hours a week on this productivity
um so how is clean code going to come to
the rescue let's have a look first of
all of what clean code is if you had to
write a sentence about what clean code
is you could quite arguably uh get away
with writing something like it's well
structured readable easy to understand
followers naming conventions has
consistent formatting and is properly
commented
uh what can you tell me about that
sentence
does anything stand out to you about
um
the last line
properly commented
normally we shouldn't write comments
comment the code should be comments kind
of the main thing here is this has
nothing to do with the computer the
computer doesn't care if your code is
well formatted or well structured or
well commented this is all about how
humans look at the code
there's a guy uh Donald cruff
he's a American Computer scientist and a
professor Emma Emeritus at Stanford
University
he was actually called the father of the
analysis of algorithms at one point and
he said this programming is not about
telling the computer what to do
it's about telling another programmer
what the computer should do
at the end of the day programming is
essentially storytelling we are all
storytellers
so
let's change context in our Heights for
a second imagine you're a Storyteller
not a programmer maybe you're an author
and you're writing a book and you're
writing a book with somebody else you're
co-authoring and the other person has
started a bit of the book already and
they're going to send you that book for
you to be able to work on
imagine if you receive a book
that's in 25 different pieces
the appendix and the uh the
the bit that goes to the front again
head cold brain not working
um table of contents are both together
on the front the middle of the chap the
middle chapters are the end and you're
trying to work out where do I add my bit
of information into this book you're
probably going to have to re-jig their
work a little bit before you can
actually do your stuff you're probably
gonna have to spend probably a few days
just
piecing it together and working out
what's going on it's not an ideal way of
working on a book I would imagine if
anybody here has been a co-author you
usually use an online
Word document type editor and you would
have everything in the correct order
you'd have a
almost like an agenda you would have a
structure
and you would be filling it out and
padding it out in places you would have
structure from the beginning
that would essentially be a clean way of
writing a book
so how can we do that with software
engineering
if we do do that with software
engineering or the code that we write
and we're going to make a couple of
we're going to get immediate benefits
from that one of them is going to be
improved productivity by writing code
that is easy to understand and maintain
as developers we're going to be faster
and more efficient in the same way as
writing a book
that's already linear for you it's going
to be easier to write software when it's
well structured
it used to be and I hope there are at
least a couple people in here who share
my
um age range
it used to be that we wrote software
that was optimized for computers because
we had so little memory on there that
having a short variable name was
actually beneficial because we could
write bigger programs because they took
less space per
IOD
something like that nowadays computers
have so much memory most things are
running in the cloud you can just scale
things up it's actually beneficial for
us to write software if it's optimized
for the next human
not for the computer
and then when it comes around to
updating a piece of code uh it's a lot
more well structured
um productivity is going to increase
there again because not only has been
easier to create it because we've got a
clear idea of what we're building as
we're building it but it's also easy
then to pick it up in the future and be
more productive when we're maintaining
that software
we also have reduced cost and this kind
of goes hand in hand if you are spending
less time maintaining and getting your
head into the code you can spend more
time on the cost so the original
investment their changes and you can see
I'm starting to use what some people
might call weaselwoods or bingo
words
um but yes the original investment is
something that we as software developers
do actually have to think about
and we get better software quality if
it's more readable
then as we're looking at code and to to
somebody's point over there code should
be comments
yes and no we'll definitely into that
but by a large yes if the code is more
readable then it means that as you're
going through software if you find a bug
or if even if a bug hasn't been reported
you might read something and go hang on
a minute this this here doesn't really
seem quite right if I if the method name
is
um give me some kind of information
based on X Y and Z and the code inside
there tells me the story of something
else
it's easier to pick that up so clean
code is going to allow us to make a
right more secure less bug written
software as well
and finally it gives us testable code
now there's an argument about how
granular granular you will make your
software components like the functions
and and procedures and methods
but if you have everything in one big
function it's really hard to do any kind
of functional testing on that
if you break it down into little Parts
it's easier to test it's easy to reuse
which goes back to maintainability but
it's easier to test as well you'll be
able to put test Suites in which then
feeds back into the better software
quality and
Etc of the the chain so every single one
of our benefits actually links into the
others we're basically giving ourselves
a huge opportunity to create much better
software that's much more maintainable
and the next person who looks at the
code is not going to hate you
we're touching on becoming a hero
okay
so what do you notice about these four
they're not written for a computer
they're also not written for us as
Developers
our managers would love to see these
now we're coming into justification
oftentimes from the security background
one of the things I'm sure we all face
is that question of how much time do we
spend making our code more secure
and it used to be that we would add
security as a feature into a backlog
item like we've written a piece of code
now here's another ticket for making it
secure and the problem with that was we
would have a Friday delivery date
and a project manager or product manager
or a lease manager would come along and
say hey Ben we really need to release on
Friday can we push these tickets out
until next week and they were all the
security ones and you're like ah I
really don't think that's a good idea
like yeah but we don't have a choice and
rather than pushing deadlines unless
they're absolutely hard deadlines rather
than pushing deadlines because it would
look bad they would release insecure
code
um lost my train of thought for a second
so um yes what do you notice
oh I'm using a different clicker I'm
used to afford backward clicker let me
just go back and find the actual right
line
uh here we go so what do you notice
about these um these are all
justifications for for our bosses they
are going to push back on anything
that's going to cost more money not
necessarily all the time that's a
blanket statement not necessarily true
all the time
um but by and large if you want to
justify something you need to get a
manager's buy-in and if you can give
them justifiable reasons here about why
doing something like this is going to
make your software better and more
secure and make your life easier in the
future they can see an advantage that
so techniques for writing we've looked
at the benefits we are starting to look
at some of the justifications you can
use to get our manager to agree to this
what are the things that we can actually
do now as software Engineers to
implement clean code
so there are four main sections that I'm
just going to name and then we'll go
through some examples so the main things
you will want to focus on the things
like naming conventions that's functions
and variables what are they called does
it does it make sense to you as you're
reading it
there's code formatting is it clear and
concise do braces align so that you can
actually tell where the loop ends
there's code organization uh have I
split things out into modules are those
modules in separate files are the files
well structured in directories can I
easily find things if I need to find
them in the future IDs will help you by
being able to train through those
functions but having a clear construct
in your brain of where those files it as
well can often help with understanding
of the code
and finally comments and documentation
and as mentioned before comments can
sometimes be bad and sometimes they can
be good we'll have a look at an example
of those in a second
so
first example long and complex functions
can somebody tell me what this does
we have a a process order which takes an
order
if the order is not null
so therefore there's something in there
then we can probably find a status on it
so if the status is pending
then we're going to have a look at the
items in that order if it has any and if
it does have items then we want to make
sure there are more than zero of those
because there's no point in fulfilling
an order that has an item with no count
in it then for each of those items in
the order we're going to make sure that
the item actually has information in it
and if so is the quantity more than zero
so I'm thinking this is probably like a
shopping cart or something
um and then what we do is we instantiate
a product based on the product ID of the
item and then if the product actually
exists in our warehouse as in it exists
in the database so we can look it up and
we can get a stock from it and the stock
that we have in the warehouse is greater
than or equal to the quantity ordered in
the order
then we reduce the stock count by the
item quantity we update the order status
to process and we save that
it's not actually that complicated is it
but it took a bit of brain jigging and
holding variables in place and looping
in my brain to work out what was going
on
it would probably take about a minute to
work it out it's not overly complex
but imagine this code instead
if the valid if the order is valid to
process then process it
cool I know exactly what's happening now
if I want to fix either these there's
probably two things I want to do I
either want to change the definition of
what a valid order is or I want to
change what happens when it gets
processed so I've already halved the
amount of code I need to look at if I
want to change the definition of whether
an order is valid to process is right
there there are three conditions and
it'll return to true or false much
easier for me to be able to look at that
in isolation by itself
if I want to change the what happens
when you process you can go through and
you can see that it Loops through all
the items and if those are valid then
it'll process the items again
contextually my brain doesn't have to
think it's just reading a story
we can change the definition of whether
or not an item is valid to process
and we can change what happens when you
process the item and we can change
whether or not a uh a valid product has
stock in count
so we're separating all of this out now
this is possibly an extreme example
but it's an example to point out that
there are ways to make code more
readable even if the first time you look
at the first piece of code that we
looked at you might think to yourself
that's actually quite readable it tells
a bit of a story
but I hope you would agree that this
tells a much neater story
this is a story you can tell your
grandchildren that will confuse them
lack of meaningful names
who can tell me what this function will
return
average excellent that took probably
about eight seconds who can tell me what
this function will return
I'm disappointed I was taking more than
eight seconds but I hope you you get
from the example that it says calculate
average tells you right at the top what
it does and again we go back to this
whole thing of not needing comments if
you look at that code there
it was fairly quick to work out that
that was an average it's probably even
quicker to know this is supposed to
return an average look of the code and
go yep that checks out if there was an
error in that code you'd probably pick
it up pretty quickly
if this was wrapped in a larger context
of a larger function or a method you'd
be looking at that going ah that does
something I'm not quite sure what
overuse of comments
to our friend over there
um
I think you probably all told me this
we'll calculate the area of a circle
because that's the first line
um could you tell me that either of
these would also calculate the area of a
circle
probably
and I'll put two examples up here
because here's an example in my mind of
something that's over optimization
I would argue the top example
where you actually specify that it's pi
times radius times radius
is clearer than the bottom one
because in the bottom one you need to
know what math.power does
and the first time I read math.pal I
thought
is that something to do with a Batman
cartoon
So Clean and Clear code isn't
necessarily making it the smallest code
possible or even the most efficient I
don't I haven't run any stats to work
out whether math or power is faster than
radius times radius but even if radius
times radius was slower I would argue go
with the one that makes more sense that
tells a cleaner story
all right lack of consistency
uh
this one here a bit of C sharp fuel
uh it's fairly straightforward it's
really easy simple it doesn't really do
anything spectacular but already some of
your heads are probably looking like
going oh I feel dirty inside
there are two issues with this code one
of them is consistency and the other one
is what happens when you have
inconsistent code
so you probably figured out that it was
mainly about the fact that sometimes
there's an underscore sometimes there's
a capital
there are standards and each language
will have its own some languages don't
have standards and it comes down to the
project or the team to make up the
standards but there should always be
standards conventions of how you name
things how you
um like do you do an increment a plus
plus or do you do uh a plus a do you put
semicolons to the end of your JavaScript
the answer is yes yes or do you choose
not to
but the other issue here is if you look
at that last circle on the bottom right
if I'd come in and this class already
existed and somebody said look we need
to add another method called get full
name which I would have used Capital G4
of course
if I typed in first name camelcase first
caps
plus space and then typed in last name
my brain would type in capital l a s t
capital n e n m e because my brain is
trying to maintain that consistency and
now I've introduced a bug I'm using an
undefined variable and yes Ides will
probably pick this up I if they didn't I
would hope you'll see ICD pipeline would
pick it up but the point is that it
shouldn't have to
code completion will probably also help
but making everything consistent in the
first place just means there's one less
thing we have to think about as
Developers
so that's the the nice version
all right let's put all of this together
and have a look some nasty nasty code
this is a bad code example do you know
how I can tell that
yes because it tells you in the class
name
okay so what are we going to do we've
got this this main function we're going
to load the user and then it says that
we're going to load a user
great it's like I've got an echo while
somebody's telling me a story check if
the user is active and authenticated and
then we check if the user is active and
the user is authenticated count attempts
I would argue that um declaring a
variable and assigning the value 0 to it
counts nothing
that's a really shitty comment
um I think if you uh just got rid of
that comment you'd probably understand
what attempts meant
while attempts is less than three we're
going to check input
check check input if we look at the
check input function
no I don't know what that is either it
just checks if the user input is valid
but the function name doesn't tell me
that it's like does it exist is it
non-blank is it valid has it been
escaped is the rate is going to a
database what does check input mean give
it a better name
then I put in a comment there with lots
of code because I don't want to actually
put lots of code in but imagine there's
a ton of code in there now we check the
user input whatever that returned was
true therefore we're going to do all of
this stuff here
um so yes these things here I do not
like what would we do instead I would
argue that if the user is authenticated
then they are also active you cannot log
in if your account is not active so I
have moved
onto the right hand side there you can
see the is user authenticated I've used
is user active in there and this is also
a really good way of speeding up some of
your calls to functions if the user is
not active you don't need to go through
the bother of checking to see whether
they're authenticated you can just
return straight out of that with false
and the rest of the code doesn't even
need to run so we've got an optimization
there
but the only thing really really dip
really care about is my ability to speak
and the other thing we really care about
on the left hand side is is the user
authenticated
because that implies that they're active
make it easier to read
Also let's take all the operations we
want to perform and put them into
another function
some of you might argue that perform
operation is a really bad function name
and I would agree with you 100
that's why it's a code sample because I
don't know what the function is either
and finally you might have noticed on
the previous slide nope wrong button
again
system error print line
how many of you have more than one
system error print line in your code
base
be truthful
three good
um if you move that into another
function and in this example it's part
of the same class but you can move it
into a different class you can have your
own logging class then allows you to not
have to go through your code and get rid
of them at the end of the day before you
push into production you can say hey if
something happens here log this if I'm
in Dev
in a development environment then I
wanted to system print line if I'm in
staging I wanted to push it into this
external logging tool that we use if I'm
in production I want to push it into
something else that's going to probably
be a bit more judicious about what
actually causes a flag and then alert us
that something's actually wrong in
production
you still want the information but the
way you want to receive that information
changes from environment to environment
so make it easy to change that for
yourself
clean code and bugs how's this actually
going to help us so we've looked at ways
that we can actually make improve
maintainability
but how does it help us with the
security side of things
um this code here
is rubbish
okay let's work out what this one does
um const H so we've got this
Handler I guess because there's a
request and a response I'm assuming RQ
and rs are requesting response this
looks to me like a node.js Express API
Handler of some sort Okay so we've got
this Handler
and we've got a request and response and
then p and U are predefined
dirty if they're assuming it's a request
is undefined if it's not undefined is
the type regular
if so do this mathematical thing if the
type is VIP
so now I'm trying to work out what the
hell is going on here so I look at the
issue ticket and says we've got an API
endpoint that allows somebody to start
the process for a loan application and
as part of that we need to work out what
interest rate we want to apply to that
loan and then approve or reject the uh
the process from continuing all right
cool a bit more context we uh so if it's
a regular user we're going to look at a
normal divided by a maximum time some
number
um yeah if their VIP we're going to make
a call to an external system or another
API endpoint to check they actually are
a VIP user and they haven't just spoofed
that bit of information in the post
request that came from the web
application if they really are then
we're going to
um oh if they're not we're going to use
the same calculation as before if they
are a VIP then we're going to give them
a 25 discount on the interest rate cool
and then we return some stuff
so this is definitely not clean code
because even I'm not sure if I got that
right and I wrote that code as badly as
I could
um so what would be um what where would
we start if we got this issue and I said
okay so some customers are being
approved for loans way higher than they
should be eligible for
reproducibility not consistently don't
you just love that how do you reproduce
this I've got no idea it just happens
sometimes it works on my machine it
doesn't work on my machine
can anybody see the bug
does this thing work it does
so where's my cursor so you're saying
in this one here
the calculation is different to this one
here you've got a Keen Eye there it says
a thousand then it says ten thousand
why do we have that number in there
three times or rather why do we have two
numbers in there
when it should just be one number three
times absolutely correct
to go through that
and get the contextual
sense of what's going on is tricky
so yes there's the 1000. what we could
do instead is say okay we're going to
have this function called process loan
application suddenly I know exactly what
it does
isn't that amazing the rate is zero and
it's probably not a great start but
we'll find out later that you should
technically not be able to return that
anyway the user is undefined if the
request is not undefined then we're
going to get the loan to value ratio for
the rate
and then if it's a VIP we're going to
check their VIP
and if they actually are a VIP then we
give them a discount of the VIP lvr
discount
how much easier was that to read
very Ben thank you
all right finally and we're getting so
close to that being a hero finally how
can we actually use this to be lazy
uh this is the only screen I have to
show you that is lazy also I've just
realized as I glance to my right
that that X should actually be a tick so
uh
blame my adult brain this is actually a
good thing not a bad thing if you're
writing clean code and you're
structuring things well and you're
naming things well and the um the
information is available to the ID most
IDs will actually help you code
why would you not want
help writing code
why would you not want help writing code
is anybody here used any of the AI based
coding assistants
uh
that's about 47 percent
Copart has been around for a while
and I only used it for the first time
three weeks ago four weeks ago
um because I sat next to a friend who
said have you tried Copart I haven't
um
top tip if you're writing code samples
for presentations the copilot is amazing
but we are now in a situation where code
is being written for us
how clean is that code there's a huge
question about how accurate and fit for
purpose is that code and that's why
anybody who says that AI is going to
steal our jobs I just laugh at because
I'm like have you seen what it produces
I mean it's great it's a great start but
we still have to verify that it does
what it does right we still have to look
at it and go through and say yes this is
what I intended
so we might end up with some code like
this
and for highlighter parts are the only
things that I typed into vs code last
night as I thought you know what I can
add another slide into this talk
create a middleware function that
as oh do you want to check a Json web
token make sure it's valid I'm like yes
how did you know because that's what
everybody does
and I said okay create a post endpoint
the response to slash posts and uses
check WT says oh I know you want you
wanted to validate the Json web token
I'm like
okay I'm scared now
but also what do you notice about this
code I mean this this would work if you
owned dev-3q3q3q3q
as a tenant name and um
but that that would probably work at a
quick lens you'd change that hostname
that you could commit it and everything
would be fine right
imagine coming back to that in the
future
it's quite readable
but whoops
why not this button here
why not get rid of
this these two lines of code of comment
right here they're not really required
anybody who has worked with any kind of
Json web token validation in an Express
endpoint
is going to be very familiar with that
block of code
um anybody who isn't would probably not
be touching that is a bit of code again
readability fit for purpose for the
person who's going to be touching it
um validate the audience and issuer
that's actually incorrect it's not
validating anything it's just providing
parameters to some object
um create a post endpoint the response
to that that's kind of cool I'd leave
that one in but there's a lot of stuff
in here that I'll change I don't need
case the signing key because case true
tells me exactly that
I don't need prevent attackers from
requesting over five per minute
again
I'm reading the code and it tells me
that
so we are going to be going into a
future where we will be using artificial
intelligence to write a lot more of our
code and my advice to you is
obviously read it make sure it's doing
what it needs to be done or what it's
supposed to be doing
um if you need to it might create a
monolith of a function consider breaking
it down and applying clean code
principle to it after the fact
then you can test it and make sure that
even though you read through it it
actually still does what you're
expecting it to do
um but don't be scared of it just use it
and then clean it up afterwards so
hopefully if you have a clean code
principle or philosophy in your
application development already then
using things like AI to help you write
code is not actually going to negatively
affect you'll only get the positive
effects of that assistance tool
all right challenges for implementing
clean code because it's never easy to
turn around to somebody and say you know
what we need to add something else to
our development process nobody wants to
add something because that just slows us
down
so deadlines will always be things I
mentioned before if you have a hard
deadline that you can't push then
obviously sometimes you're up
a certain creek without a paddle
but often deadlines can be moved so
think about the
the
pros and cons of if we move the deadline
but we get better code at the end of it
that's probably a good thing right often
if you have clients you're writing for
as opposed to if you're working for your
own internal products
talking to those clients and saying hey
this is actually going to make it better
it's going to make your product better
it means there's going to be fewer
issues in the future and then when you
want changes made in the future we can
do those faster most of them are going
to be you know what that probably makes
sense let's give it a try
changing requirements again somebody
comes along and says hey we want to
change this now all of a sudden not only
it's easier to find where you need to
change it but then as you're as you're
making those changes we're often in one
of these situations of we just need to
get this over the line right it's a
simple change let's just put it in maybe
you've added some extra lines of code
into
improve the the functionality of a
certain routine that you've written
but you haven't stopped and taken a step
back and thought should I put that into
its own component its own function
um have I put too many comments in is
this actually readable
sometimes you'll look a bit of code and
you'll get similar variable names
especially when you're on Loops in loops
because they're dealing with the same
kind of thing
so you might have like a temperature and
then you're looping through and you're
looking at the temperature from every
hour from the day before and you're
comparing with the current temperature
now you've got current temperature and
previous temperature and it starts
getting and then if you put another loop
inside there because you want to do
something else you've got another kind
of temperature so maybe it is breaking
that out so that contextually you can
look on one block of code and know
exactly what's going on under the hood
without having to keep multiple variable
spaces and Scopes or variable um the
values of the variables and the Scopes
of those variables in your head at the
same time
and code based size and complexity as
code base gets bigger it's going to be
hard to do we also have two issues here
if you're starting a brand new project
you're in a position where you can say
hey let's do clean code from the
beginning if you are picking up a
project that's got two and a half
million lines of code that has never had
clean code philosophy apply to it and
you think you know what it would
probably be a really good idea to do
this
everyone's going to shiver because do
you know how long it takes to clean two
and a half million lines of code
has anybody here cleaned I don't know
more than a hundred thousand lines of
cloud
people that's cool 500 000.
one so I'm just going to go straight and
say how big was it
two and a half million I guess to the
beginning I should have asked that
straight away Congratulations by the way
um I don't know how you did it it would
probably be
a mammoth operation right
the other thing to consider is just do
it step by step if you're going to go in
and touch a piece of code then clean
that bit of code
make it easier to read break it out make
it more functional whatever you need to
do so the next time you come back and
look at that code you're thinking I'm so
glad I did that and then when you look
at a piece of code you didn't feel like
and then you do to that piece of code
and then you do it to another piece of
code and over a year or two years or
four years or however long it takes you
will get to a point where you've cleaned
quite a lot of that code
and the advantages the code that you
haven't cleaned you haven't touched for
four years
so you're probably not going to touch it
for another four years if it works
don't fix it
if it doesn't work fix it and make it
easier for the next person who then has
to look at it again
so it is possible but don't take it on
as one big chunk
so I've called these challenges but in
describing them to you I hope you've
heard that they're not actually
challenges I guess they are a challenge
it's a challenge accepted kind of a
challenge
there are things that we can't overcome
there are ways around them they are not
blockers to adopting clean code
so we finish with a business case
how do we actually turn around to our
manager project manager team lead and
say hey I've got this great idea
we should spend even more time on
stuff
add another thing to the process they're
like I love you that's a great idea can
we just ship this thing
okay return on investment yes because it
always comes down to the money
if you can make a financial
justification it's going to be much
easier to sell it doesn't always always
come down to the money sometimes there
are other reasons why somebody might
take it on but if you can also give
Financial
justifications for adopting something
it's going it's gonna be so much easier
for them to then push it up the line and
get that approved
so what have you spent less time reading
less time maintaining less time fixing
less time debugging code that sounds
like a good thing if you can go to your
manager and say that then they'd surely
be quite happy
you can even go to them with the stats
that we had before remember we had this
this is the chart version before
remember we were spending 10 of our time
on good code we're spending 51 of our
time on Bad Code
imagine if we halved the amount of time
we spent on the bad code
what would that do to this pie chart
it would increase the good code
not by double but by three and a half
times
because statistics are amazing
so if you can go to your boss and say if
we just have time it takes to read our
code we can be three and a half times as
productive
at the cost of a little bit of extra
process
you'd be mad or she'd be mad to say no
at least I'll be mad if I was the
manager to say no I can't speak for your
managers
hopefully they'll be okay with the idea
and lastly you might be looking at this
going yes that's that's all all very
well but help is a hand I've already
mentioned things like AI coding it's uh
it's going to take echo of the comments
and turn into code that's pretty much
usable just need to check it and there
are also tools that hand I mentioned at
the beginning that I'm a developer
advocate for Sona I'm not here on a
sales pitch for it
um but we do we are sponsoring so if you
want to come down have a chat with us we
do have tools to help with clean code
um
uh but basically if I could just finish
off by summarizing why you should
consider it if you haven't or if you are
congratulations on on being part of the
pack uh you get self-documented
documenting code
reasonability readability becomes
maintainable there are fewer bugs and
allows you to be lazy again it's going
to type it for you AI types it for you
make it clean make it easy to follow
colleagues will love you because
suddenly the whole team improves
productivity but best of all your boss
will love you
that'll make you the hero
thank you very much for your time if you
fancy uh asking any questions I think
we've got some time but if not as I say
come down and grab the other booth yes